you know how do we make it easy for
people to remember right
they know the genes and there's a genome
right
and so essentially your x-posom
right is is that unit that refers to
your environment your total exposure to
the environment
so the genome is to your genes and your
exosome
is to your environment right now it's at
the level of metabolome because it's
what we can prove right it's what we can
show objectively
that here here is what's improved right
uh it's like i don't rely on anything
subjective but
usually and uh the case is like i'm
feeling better right
uh i i'm i'm i'm uh i'm feeling
better or i feel so much better or some
some um
husbands uh would go i'm only here
because my wife
told me so then they would come six
months later and they go dr ted you know
i thought i was already feeling better
but i didn't know that it was possible
to feel this way
so i tell them my goal actually in
getting you here is to get you addicted
to the feeling of wellness
so you know that when you get off
balance you know what it is that
uh that you're off balance right
why you know people say they they're
biohacking all sorts of things right
this is a framework by which you can
make
you can hang all of your hacks you could
look at
epigenetics you know uh bioenergetics
uh microbiota uh got microbiota
mitochondria
the exposomics chronobiology
evolutionary medicine
and you could hang all of your hacks in
there in a logical way
right there's a logic now you're not
just saying
oh it's because they're saying it's good
for me someone's opinion may contradict
yours
where's my friend alan it's all about
your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
i'm your host alan saakian
i am so pumped for this episode we're
going to be talking about
health optimization we have dr
ted achokoso joining us on the show hi
ted
hi ellen thanks so much for coming on
the program i'm so
pumped for this i adore everything that
you're doing
with synthesizing our
most cutting edge technological advances
in understanding our biometrics and
optimizing our health and that
is just going to be so paramount for
economic efficiencies
for intelligence and artistic
efficiencies
so i am pumped and you are so
optimistic with the way you say that you
know my putting all of those together
is just with my frustration on how we
have
all of these sciences that have advanced
but we're not using them in the clinics
to optimize our health you know we're
just
all doing disease disease disease and
i'm fed up with that
so me too and same thing with all these
other brilliant
um scientists and and and doctors and
and people that are really at the edge
of biotech that know
what you know that you're she going to
share be sharing with us
is that they're fed up with that and
we're cut
we're coming in uh hot for the future
right now
for those that don't know ted's
background i'll read it to you guys
is that he is the global founding
pioneer of health optimization medicine
and practice
home hope which detects and corrects
imbalances at the level of the
metabolome
leveraging multi-omics epigenetics
bioenergetics gut immune systems
chronobiology exposomics and
evolutionary medicine
he's also the founder of biobalance
institute in manila
providing proof of concept that health
optimization medicine and practice is an
economically superior clinical practice
he's double board certified in
nutritional and anti-aging medicine
with focus on ai medical informatics and
mathematics of consciousness
and wrote the first ever connectome of c
elegans
into a book and you can find all of his
links in the bio below homehope.org
biobalanceinstitute.com as well as
truescript
transcriptions.com all right ted i want
to start with
this is probably the most important from
first place for us to start with and
then we're going to get into what we
were talking about
in the intro is how did you at such a
young age because we we talk about this
so much on the program is
parsing for signal and inspiring young
kids especially
to parse for signal related to not only
what are the most
uh ancient spiritual understandings of
metaphysics and the nature of reality
but also around what are the most
cutting edge sciences
and then bringing those two together and
and also the kids
unique gift and identifying that you at
such a young age were able to figure out
how to get how to
how to parse for that signal and became
and achieved all of your medical
successes so much earlier than most
people
do how did you figure all of that out
how did you begin parsing for that
signal at such a young age
actually um and i have said this
before and i insist on it especially on
children
it's not to stifle their curiosity you
push
your kids and younger people to be
curious about things
and for the parents not to be
to provide pat answers to things like
god made this and god made that and
suddenly you know the child becomes
lazy what i call intellectual sloth that
plagues our society
right you allow them to discover you
allow them to get
bored and they watch a cutter a
caterpillar and then they wonder what
happens to a caterpillar you know when
you when you couple that
with the proper guidance and you know a
certain industriousness on the part of
the parents or the teachers
to nurture the curiosity with the proper
facts
right then you could actually instill
in in a child that there are certain
patterns
that nature follows yes and then they
when
and then when they realize that when
nature follows
um certain patterns and then
they could realize that okay then there
is such a thing called mathematics that
is the science of abstract pattern
right you could see that they could you
could abstract for example x plus x
equals 2x then
a one apple plus one apple equals two
apples
right and but then when it's
uh y it's uh you know x plus y so one
apple plus one orange
equals one apple and one orange then you
could immediately see
that the pattern can be immediately
abstractable and then you
instill in them a love for abstract
patterns
and uh that will that will
spur them into you know more curiosity
about well what other patterns exist and
pretty soon
you know for mathematical purists out
there for example
they really love the beauty of being
able to obstruct those patterns and they
make these discoveries that way
but for us who are you know i'm
undergrad in biology right and
and uh for me it's looking at
the uh what fascinates me and
what drives my curiosity always even as
a younger child is
how did we evolve you know how did we
come to be this way
what were the factors in there that's
why for example an interest in
evolutionary biology
is uh you know i i you know it should be
taught to everyone
you know um uh evolutionary should be
taught every
er er every everyone because it shows
you how we evolved how did we get here
right and then as you mature you should
be taught uh the new field now that
there's a new field called evolutionary
psychology right yeah why do we
why do we behave the way we do yeah and
uh
when you see that that's shaped by
evolution
and it's also and evolution is shaped
the way the brain is wired the way we're
wired
right and then um and then for us to
be understanding the economic economics
where we're in
everyone should be taught you know game
theory
evolutionary game theory you know these
are things are fundamental but
you could see what i'm driving at right
yes one is the capacity to see patterns
what's the definition of genius right
is is the capacity
to see patterns where others say that
there are none
and the patterns exist right and the
definition of madness
is the capacity to see patterns where
others say that there are none and
they're really none
right so so
there is the thin line uh but
um and even if you take a look at iq
tests and all that kind of stuff
you know it's really your capacity to to
see patterns and to
do abstractions through those patterns
yes the clearer you see them
you know the faster the faster you are
at looking so
um i have this concept alan of what i
call
i like verbalizing nouns so
and i i love fractal mathematics right
so
um um you know i look at the
core pattern you know what gets iterated
over and over what gets repeated over
and over
right so for evolution it's really very
simple uh
and um you know uh it's it's a random
variation
and narrow selection right and that's
darwin's version
but now we have already abstracted that
right so we have
we have essentially random variation and
you know
environmental selection but the unit of
selection now differs
right so for richard dawkins for example
you could see that his unit of selection
is a gene
is the gene that's being selected for
for darwin it was populations
right and um i was
hearing uh an evolutionary biologist
from harvard actually interpreting this
all wrong
you know that the the unit of selection
in darwin's case
is not the individual it's the
population that's being selected for
right it's it's kind of like
pre-industrial england
right when when there were a lot of
white moths and then suddenly
with industrialization there was a lot
of suit around
right and suddenly the black moth
started to getting selected for because
they could conceal better
and the white moths started getting
eaten by the patients because they could
be seen um they could be seen right so
you could see
very easily that these are the kinds of
things that um
that selection does
but the unit of selection is different
for memes which was introduced by
um by dawkins right um
with not the bastardized internet meme
that we have now but if
the unit of selection for society and
culture right when you are going to
school they
what they're doing is they're
transferring names right and memes are
behaving like genes they're like viruses
they transfer
right and these are these are like you
know um sayings
uh like like maxims like uh you know the
early bird catches the worm right
and i like to bastardize that a lot i
say the early bird catches the early
worm
because you could see how this little
memes would affect your behavior
right so um
so you could see that it all stems from
early on pushing uh pushing the
curiosity
um allowing for uh the child to
identify you know that there's certain
core patterns there that get repeated
even if it's hidden right yeah and then
an abstraction of that pattern to
something else that's
manipulable right yes yes so now you
could see a child growing to
manipulate you know a mathematic a
geometry of 64 dimensions
you know which you could never imagine
right because
introspection is usually all wrong right
you because you cannot imagine a
geometry of something that has a 64
dimensions
but you know sure there there are there
are
geometries now that are occurring beyond
space and time so
you know um if you for example it occurs
to them
that hey you know i can regard space and
time as an illusion and
physics is finding now the space time is
an illusion so
you could see the ramifications that are
very vast
and we need these kinds of motivations
for the younger people
not just to [ __ ] survive and
reproduce yeah i mean
because that's ordinary yeah that's so
or
dinner yeah that's as we do this within
two standard divisions
as as as i like to say you know if
that's what we do
and then we we destroy this earth
right and then so we go in spaceships
and colonize another livable planet
survive and reproduce erect that planet
again and go somewhere else i think
oh you know then we're not doing our job
right we're not doing a job in
determining
where we want to bring our species to
and
i i presume that this the reason why you
want to bring out podcasts like this is
that
you know how can we have a species
awareness
that brings us forward to where we
really want to bring ourselves
to in relation to the network of other
species that are out there in this
planet
it is our one and only host at the
moment right
and we're destroying it at a really
alarming rate
you know so um and then for and then
from and then from there
and then you you go back like uh oh you
know
the reason where those so many climate
change and ires and all that
is is you know i i usually don't
like to say this is it's just plain
ignorance
right there's a certain as dawkins
uh likes to say you know there's a
certain
form of intellectual courage right
enable
to be able to do this uh to make these
kinds of assertions
and and that intellectual courage
actually uh for example if you're
looking at climate change
you have to have a fundamentals of um of
uh the second law of thermodynamics at
least but who wants to know that
let alone want to know the the structure
of fermions and bosons and all
and weapons and quartz we evolved
right we evolved to like to know stories
because it's as
that's how we evolve for survival right
and for reproduction so we like to tell
stories around you know that's why we're
good at conspiracies
we're good at all of this uh things that
have plots and
motivations etc but we're so poor
at statistics like for example you know
the
the amount of car accidents are a lot
more than taking a plane for example
and we we cannot realize that right
because we are made for
a nomadic group of five to seven people
we're not intended to to take a look at
populations
you know certain laws are formulated
that way or regulations are familiar the
way the the seat belt law
you know massachusetts didn't want to do
the seatbelt well because it crinkled
their clothes
right but uh from a rational they were
the last ones to enact it in law but
you know from from from from uh from a
rational
point of view means are you thinking
statistically and
this is the effect you know from
when you get child curious and
and then um you know superimposing
science
and and mathematics you know and uh
uh and evolution how we evolved yeah
and how we came to think this way then
there is a chance for
us not to think this way to think in a
different way
right um yes and
and so we can we can think of different
solutions
right for different solutions for
issues and for the and that's why for
example
i was thinking about health right you
know we say we're talking about health
optimization
i know you've already gone far right but
yeah
let me hit let me hit the ball back and
then we'll we'll keep going
this okay this this intro segment has
been really awesome how you explained
when the child is uh
if has the full curiosity
fully enabled and
then also there is the guiding influence
of
of intelligent parents that have
understood
that there are these patterns that
emerge and then by
in a sense abstracting out those
patterns
into pareto efficient ways of teaching
the child
about those patterns and also for the
child to they themselves
watch those patterns and for them to
fully embody the recognition
of those patterns including the patterns
of
things like why there's perennial
spirituality around the entire planet
pointing at the same nature of reality
understanding so then there's this big
synthesis
that happens for the kid as they follow
their creativity and they follow their
curiosity and they're understanding the
science patterns and the spiritual
patterns and they understand
their own unique artistry role i really
like that and also
i like just the classical bell curve
understanding where
in that center is just this idea of okay
uh have fun and reproduce and then on
like
on the on the on the non-progressive
side is still notions of wanting to own
other humans or
violence or kill and then on the
hyper-progressive side these strokes of
genius these kids that
and and adults that may be two or three
standard deviations
up the bell curve are usually the ones
that like you said are able to
abstractly
reason these patterns in new creative
ways
in solving the greatest challenges that
exist
in creating the greatest art and i i
like that a lot
as long as as long as uh the people
within two standard deviations
don't drown out you know those people
yes and it's very easy to drown out
because
as people who are wired for survival and
reproduction
that's the even our symbolic
manipulation is such
right it's easier to memorize the
characters in your telenovela
than it is or in your daytime soap than
it
is to memorize the families of hearts
and leptons
for example yes because they have no
story right yeah and
that's so well said so we need to tell
the story we need to tell an
exciting story that makes it even more
fun to know about the families of
elementary particles
and and beyond yeah and beyond well you
know
and then uh you know make them question
it later are there really families of
elementary particles is there
you know like like a donald huffman in
the case against reality in this uh
book right you know is this really what
it is
you know it's what we're seeing what
we're seeing or is it yeah yeah
um and that's curiosity right and that's
curiosity
i like your your point is very right
that center of
the of the bell curve if if the idea
that i've been
pushing around a lot is that the people
that are in the sense two or three
standard deviations up the bell curve
their general um purpose in a sense
also is to uh help
the people that are in the um in the
in the maybe one standard deviation to
zero
range up uh the bell curve to to
help them do a pull-up in a sense to to
go to the next level
so basically you know like eric
weinstein has the idea of the portal
like the idea that you can create a
portal
to help people in that center part of
the bell curve
go through the portal through these
stories and patterns that we can
disseminate to them to inspire them
to move up the bell curve and let's just
let's just jump into because we could
spend
we could spend so much of our time in
just that in just that section it's just
the beginning
um okay in general yes yes
that's one little thing uh sherington in
1946-47
you know uh he had he had a uh lecture
uh
uh royal royal uh society where
he said that you know the movement of
society as regards
you know it's science technology culture
mathematics etc
in any one of those fields say physics
right um it's like an amoeba
it throws off pseudopods or false feet
right uh
you know it goes in one direction and
all you need
is just a few of those geniuses pulling
and pulling and pulling
you know until pretty soon the entire
body of society
is yes moved forward that's right so
and and and that's that's what the best
that we can hope to happen
yeah right yes and what we don't like
happening is like
several of these pseudopodia being
thrown in different directions
you want a strong pull towards one so
you could pull
you know the the the social cultural
zeitgeist forward yes
yes yes you can pull the scientific side
guys forward yes
yes anyway yes beautifully said i loved
this first section it was so powerful
okay now this net this next section is
kind of the
the central um ethos and thesis
of what you represent and i think that
um it's also represent what you mean
yeah
yeah and me and me i mean this is a huge
pillar of what i'm passionate about and
have interviewed
hundreds of people about this exact
topic and so
this topic is basically the
idea that we are now able to take
a constant stream
of our biometrics and we are
able to tweak
where there is a
imbalance in a sense dr aubry de gray
uses the analogy and you're going to
give us some as well
of the fact that like why does a jet
engine on an airplane have
hundreds of sensors but why do we see
the doctor
one time a year right yeah so these
types of things and so
and so into the future and you're going
to hit this back right now is just that
the this is the future is this constant
stream
and then the ability to correct
imbalances and then for us to live
healthier moment to moment healthier
stronger
more creative and also longer and so
that's this general idea and we're going
to get into a bunch of the subtopics on
this but yes go ahead and um
and hit it hit it off no you you said
you know you had all the the adjectives
you can live
healthier momentum etc i i
just aim for one i just want
to live equanimously yeah with
equanimity
right yes um uh which is
the highest form of love and the highest
form of love is peace and
yes highest form of peace is equanimity
so um
you you actually already hit on it when
you know the jets have so many sensors
and we used to think
that the body didn't have uh
as much of molecules that can be sensed
right and uh when you go to an illness
medicine doctor
essentially you already have a flat tire
right your your heart has already
given out right or you
already have an overheated engine you
already have a fever from an infection
right so as an illness medicine doctor
myself i'm a trained interventional
neuroradiologist right
um we know how to repair stuff
we we bring your car to the
you know to the garage and we know how
to do retrospectively
oh this is actually it's not your
carburetor
you know it's this you know and so
our diagnostics are are um basically
retrospective
right so we know how to do repair right
and
we do repair uh our antibiotics have to
work on populations we're
dealing with populations all the time
right
of of uh of individuals because
hey you know the technique for open
heart surgery has to work
consistently throughout the world right
if you if you do it so
but when you go and and and do that
you're just looking at repairing your
system right
and then the concept of endless medicine
of prevention
is disease prevention so the the
diabetic society will say this is how
you prevent diabetes
this is how and then the neurology
societies this is how you prevent
alzheimer's and this is how you prevent
you know um
and so on so forth so if someone who has
hypertension and someone who has
cognitive decline
and someone who has cancer and someone
has diabetes
you know they will follow three four
different kinds of
of prevention guidelines and what the
hell is that you know
um yeah so notice i used hell
all right i usually use another
expletive
but are you really expecting patients to
do that
but it turns out that um you know it
you know our cars are so much better now
because every three thousand miles comes
a warning light that says okay
time for you to bring your car to the
garage and then
when the temperature is rising it shows
exactly
you know what the temperature is and
gives you a warning that you're about to
hit critical level right
or when your tire pressure is going down
it's it's uh gives you the level of your
tire pressure and which
tire right yeah initially we didn't have
those kinds of diagnostics and medicine
right so all we were taught in illest
medicine
was pathology you know what's a disease
you know and how to repair it
pharmacology
by drugs or surgery cut him up or do a
combination of both
right yeah so so now but we also didn't
have the access
in terms of the instrumentation to see
at that level but now in the last really
like
100 years we got this instrument because
of the development
of science and technology right we are
now able to take a look inside the cell
in fact uh there's a reason why my
medical school classmates hate me right
because you're being dragged right back
into biochemistry inside a cell
whereas before you couldn't measure
those metabolites or small molecules
right
now you could measure them before you
will
you will just say oh just take vitamin c
and just
take vitamin e now i actually resent
that question
being asked of me it's like why don't
you [ __ ] measure it and then
take it if you need it right because all
of those can be measured now
yes it turns out that metabolomics which
is they're all mixed that's in there
clinical metabolomics which is the use
of it in the clinics it's
um it's already 40 years old right but
it's only hitting the clinics right now
wow but when you are dealing with
health not disease you must have some
objective measure
of what it is that's going out of
balance you know it's a playbook
from uh illness medicine you diagnose
and treat disease
right so in health you detect and
correct imbalances because
there's no disease right and if if
there's a disease underlying that
you set the disease aside for the
specialist and you
balance the uh imbalance of hormones and
nutrients
and other metabolites that are in there
right
um and and uh if you
place those values between the values of
uh when you were 21 and 30 years old
right yeah yeah
interesting then you're when you're at
your peak homeostatic capacity
yes yes yes okay except for
except for values like uh vitamin d for
example
vitamin d is actually hormone i call it
the hormone named vitamin d right but
so then do we have the cat those are
evolutionarily determined right so
they're evolutionary determined values
that came before us
right so there is this catalog in a
sense of
of optimized but then alan's
uh 21 year old uh catalog
of of of biometrics for an optimized
uh um equanimity and equilibrium and
homeostatic capacity
onward is different is somewhat similar
but also different than ted's
so and yes yes but it falls within a
range
right it's usually higher your needs for
certain things is usually higher
right and right now i've i've seen for
example
um uh uh
21 22 year olds with growth hormone
levels of like
of that of a 70 year old you know you
could see how
how um how we've changed a lot
um people in the new york versus south
also geographically
right or in the by the equator i mean or
versus on
towards the polls yeah yeah and also
um you know it's not only that the use
of plastics for example
they're endocrine disruptor systems
right they disturb your hormonal levels
like for example they did a i think it
was like 60 000
men in europe you know between ages 21
to 30
and they found out already drops in
testosterone levels
um you know which used not to be there
so
what we use as a as a range is not what
you use
for illness medicine right when when
when
clients or clients because they're not
sick right or patients come back
and say oh look my thyroid hormone is
normal
well that's just enough not to make you
sick
right yeah so it's like a in when you
say
in nutrition the rda or the recommended
dietary allowance
is just enough not for you to incur the
deficiency but it's not the optimal
value for you yes yes okay so let's
let's
visualize this as well you have a you
have a really good visual that i'll um
embed here but you have this you have
this
general idea of scale that
um we can envision here where you have
an idea of what's happening at this
quantum biophysics level and then you
have what's happening at the atomic
level at the molecular level the
macromolecular level
organelle level cell level tissue
organ organ systems and organisms so you
have that
increase and then and then what you have
is you have
um it's it's really it's at this
intracellular
level is the focus right now and at this
intracellular level
there are three categories pretty much
there's optimal
sub-optimal and illness and and
and you what we're talking about is
basically
keeping your biometrics at the optimal
level
so even when they start going into what
are called like these preliminary
phases of sub-optimal levels
um that we can have those interventions
to return them
to optimal levels and these can be
measured via
right it's just like you know your
windshield wiper
um fluid is low top it off that may be
what you have low levels of alpha lipoic
acid you have low levels of vitamin b1
b2 or something and those are like the
newer
dashboards now that you have now it's
available to us
unfortunately it cannot you know those
are
the fundamental functions of cells so
we're made of organs
and underneath the organs are the
specialized cells like
you know your your beta cells in your in
your pancreas for example that produce
insulin
but underneath all of these organs and
all of these specialized cells
there's a fundamental cell that has to
run it is a nucleus it has a
mitochondria it has a cytoplasm
you know it has a plasma reticula you
know um
you know it and it has cell membranes
and it has a cytoplasm and no one's
taking care of that
and that's fundamental right yes so so
health optimization is basically focused
on health maintenance
right it's maintaining like when you're
looking at your dashboard
in your car and saying oh this is slow
and that's low you know oh this is
this is uh overheating oh i need to
change oil now
now we actually have the technology to
do
that which is through metabolomics right
and i chose metabolomics for two reasons
one the tests for them already mature
meaning we could prove to illness
medicine people like
hey look you know remember those krebs
cycle intermediates that you just used
to memorize
uh here they are here are the levels and
usually they call me back and they go
achakoso what do i do with this i said
ah so anyway because it's used for
health right
it's it's fundamental so when you are
doing health optimization you don't do
one organ at a time
right you do the fundamental cell in all
of your body
yes you gave this really good example is
basically if you
go and you um target the specific like
pancreatic
cell that is starting to have a little
bit closer towards
sub-optimal what you do is if you and i
and i want to see if you make the
correction it basically does all of the
downstream
much better yeah now now will you teach
me
yeah make no claims because illness
medicine will
will you know shoot me for that and
that's the reason why functional
medicine
you know has a lot of fights with other
illness medicine doctors right
but for me it's enough to move
uh the the values of your vitamins your
your macronutrient components like your
essential amino acids and so on
and your your uh micronutrients your
vitamins
minerals you know and cofactors and your
hormones
if you move them to to the optimal
levels
then you see the effects without any
claims right
yes yes the system tends to correct
itself
yes it's like it's like in very simple
terms it's like huh i've been sitting
for a long time my back hurts and then
you go and you swim
and then you come and then right when
you're out of the pool you're like oh my
gosh i feel so much better
so that's the intervention towards
optimal at the organism
um higher level now ted i wanna i wanna
ask you this
at um let's talk about this how do we
take
a sample from my body
to gain the the intracellular
metabolomic
knowledge of what sugars what lipids
what nucleotides
um etc our uh our our
amino acids are are there and what
um and then where they're out of range
the ideas
then some are out of range and then how
do you give an intervent
like how do you analyze that is that
through mass uh sp
spec spectrometry and then um
from there then how do you um provide
the intervention so
walk us through that whole cycle um so
um what you do they do is uh they take
uh
urine blood uh for me i take stool
samples because i have to take
check your gut microbiota right they're
a separate organ
they're not considered a postnatal organ
in the body
um which influence which is a major
influence on your immune system
right yes um uh and um uh
so it's a blood urine and so uh we
send them out a metabolomics lab
um so so essentially
they have all of this um uh
uh you know the gold standard right now
is what they call the lcm sms or the
liquid chromatography
um mass spectrometromatory but
it's already found like they're
quadrupoles and blah blah blah
the newer uh you know and right now it's
a race
to provide uh to to to
get to the protocols with the least
invasive sampling
like for example you now know the sensor
on the toilet
so that you don't even have to send it
in or
or you know google some
contact lenses right now you have the
continuous monitoring
uh over here but that's individual right
uh that's uh for for individual use if
if you're like weird like us who like to
you know i puncture myself three times a
week for my blood ketone
levels and from blood sugar even if i'm
not diabetic right
yeah yeah um yeah so so um
so after that so the the results come in
and what's nice is that they've already
done
enough statistical analysis to give you
you know uh what is the suggested
um uh amount that should be given
to the client it's already there however
you need to adjust
right you need to adjust things um
like like for example um
uh for example you see like for example
the
the uh the zinc level
is very very high right for the patient
so you you prefer the client
right and interest season and you ask
you know have you been taking lots of
of um zinc lozenges and yeah it's
artificially elevated then you'll see
the copper dropping
right so you could see that uh the
system knows
you know there are counter balances to
things if you take too much thing the
copper will drop
you know that's just the way you know
you you will get the balance
by through evolution right um
and so so after that then
the way so you you come to me the the
reason why it's nice is because this
lens itself
it lends itself to telemedicine right or
telehealth practice
yeah because you never have to see your
client or you never have to see your
patient
because you cannot say hello how are you
molecule you know i
you know how are you feeling today you
can't do that you have to look at the
values
you know of the molecules themselves
what are the levels like
like you're gonna say hello b12 you know
uh
um what's your status today you can't uh
but for for most clients uh so
essentially you
you take a look and you essentially do a
protocol
for them right which which ones are to
be taken um
before meals as soon as they will wake
up before they
before they take a meal while they're
eating especially those who
who have taken too many proton pump
inhibitors like nexium
and so on you know where you're giving
them like a beta in
hydrochloride acid to acidify your
stomachs you know
and also so there's a protocol that goes
on and then
things that you take after a meal right
and then things that you take before
bedtime
so because you know hormones follow uh
they earn a level you know there's a
certain
pattern to all of these things of course
if you take alpha lipoic acid before
meals your blood sugar will go down
right and you will feel busy because
it's a hypoglycemic agent
so you you should you know that's why i
i started this whole
health of musician medicine and practice
in order to be able
to to teach this the clinical practice
is very simple
you measure the metabolites right and
you know that they are in a network
if you touch one metabolite or you touch
one hormone the other hormone will
will respond that's why i don't like
oh you should replace your testosterone
without replacing all the other things
that you need to replace
right it's it's a bad practice because
they're all in a network and as you know
my life is about networks
so yeah um and so
you move the you give them i usually
give them
supplements for the first 90 days
because even if they say well dr ted i'm
gonna
uh you know i'm gonna eat properly i
promise and blah blah and
you ask some okay what foods are high in
in koenza and cute 10 and they don't
know okay what foods are high in
uh alfalfa acid they don't know right so
uh for the first 90 days just to catch
up with the deficiencies i
i tell them look you didn't get
to these deficiencies overnight this
occurred over time
with your habits with your lifestyle and
with everything else this is what it's
showing
let's catch up as fast fast as possible
so
you know uh the improvement can come
uh anywhere within two weeks like if
you're doing hormone therapy or
you know uh three to nine months if
you're doing uh nutrient nutrient
therapy
and you you're a measure whether or not
you're actually
addressing all these things like yeah
yeah yeah um
yeah because you gain or you gain
even after two because you're you're
taking again because there's
so many sensors right on this jet now
that we're getting the frequent readouts
of improvements
now is there is there is is there like
you said that you
there is a there's the process of once
the analysis comes back from the
the metabolomics this multiomics
analysis with all this
mass spectrometry and liquid
chromatography and stuff like that all
this complicated technological equipment
they come back and all these numbered
readouts
they're showing the they're comparing
right you
gave you gave this um really good
example you said they're
they're comparing the individual
to the reference population so the
reference population
is like thousands and thousands of
people
and the and the averages and then your
individual is either in the red or in
the
you know in the on on either of these
two sides or in the screen and
yeah yes at that particular age at that
age
too specific which is very important
because for example
and this is example that i give you know
most most people don't know that when
you get the value of a thyroid hormone
they don't know what the reference range
is just there
either you're hypothyroid or
hyperthyroid and you're given a range
right that's the illness medicine range
what you know they didn't know that the
way that got collected
initially was that was the thyroid
hormone levels of uh
for anywhere anywhere from three years
old to 94 years old
so why should i rely on that particular
data collection right um
how am i going to optimize if that's a
range yeah that's good for illness
right but it's not going to be good for
optimizing health
you see so you have to go to the optimal
range when your
body was physiologically supposed to be
at its best
right yes yes and then now teach us
teach us about this so
if there's um uh you know let's take me
27
um we say we give my continuous
stool and urine samples and we're
getting back the this biometric
metabolomic readouts
um now when when we're when you're
consult like let's say you're consulting
me as the client um right this is again
this is way
pre this is health optimization there's
no
um this is pre any um any sub-optimal
levels
um now now let's say that um when you
get the readout
back and you're analyzing it and you see
that there's
maybe the beginnings of a sub-optimal
level here here
now walk us through this process how do
you
know what supplements
for for me or what um what physical
interventions for me to go do um what
nutrition what sleep uh how do you
know these yeah specific things okay
yeah um
and now you are you are now in the realm
of lifestyle
that's why the other omics are in there
okay
uh so when when i get it
i i treat it exactly as
illness medicine doctors would do it
right
it's like okay here's what you're
deficient in but i will move
the entire network not just one right
you know that all of those for example
there's the
regeneration network right it's vitamin
e
and there's you know lipoic acid and so
and vitamin c and so on there they're
regenerated by one another
you cannot just erase one of those
antioxidants without erasing others so
you have to have a knowledge of how
these things are
wired together how the how the uh
chemistry is networked by the body right
to to regenerate its own antioxidants
for example
and you have to know which particular
which particular amino acids
you know would be uh for example you are
uh you know i i see that you you lack
vitamin b6
automatically i should know that
you probably are also suffering from
some form of
a mild depression or just uh feeling the
blues etc etc
because vitamin b6 is responsible for is
is a cofactor in the generation of a
serotonin
uh neurotransmitter so there's a lot of
stuff
that uh fundamental that you should be
knowing you know uh when when you're
making
this uh this protocol so when you come
to me
i look at that as a whole right it's not
piecemeal
the difference that i do with illness
medicine doctors
is that hey okay i tell illness medicine
doctors here it is here are the results
what they do is they try to just give
everything you can't right
because you have to know which one is
network to what
and that's your value as a health
optimization
doctor or practitioner is that the value
you provide because you know all of that
right now you also know that these
things are affected by
nutrition your gut microbiota for
example
uh in as little as 72 hours you know
when you're eating you
travel to different country and you're
eating different food your microbiota
will change drastically
right you know it will change the way
the way it's absorbing food you know uh
that
it's like an ecosystem in there some of
the um uh
species will grow more some will grow
less when you're in italy eating too
much pasta
you know then your your carbohydrate
loving
organisms will overgrow you know so
these are the kinds of things now that
affect right so
when you're like for example i had a i
had a
a patient a client in fact the doctor
who loved eating canned food right
and even if even if tin
is already banned in in the canning
process
you know he is old enough to accumulate
you know before
the banning of thin right so you could
actually see the thin
levels right and this is why i don't
emphasize the
the genome it's because the genome you
cannot see
mercury toxicity in the genome you
cannot see cadmium toxicity
interesting the farther you go away
from from the genome right so this is
the genome the proteome and then
metabolism
and transcriptome genome transcription
proteome metabolism yeah
so the further get away from that
the the more you get into the
physiological and the environmental
effects yes
yes yes and and so now
that's where the exosome comes in right
there
is your total environmental exposure to
things
like uh you know to phototoxicity the
kinds of light that you use
right you gave you gave these examples
uh
in the in the talk you used um
you used as your examples you gave
electromagnetic smog today is
hundreds of times greater than 130 years
ago
and 5g is coming around the corner
people have electromagnetic
hypersensitivity
we the stress on the living cells
disturbing immune systems
creating oxidative stress inhibiting
tissue repair
so what so that's this that's this
exosome
yeah that's the extrasome so the role of
a health immunization doctor is to
identify
you know what is it in your exosome that
is
beneficial or harmful to your health
right because part of your exosome is a
nagging
spouse yeah you know that yeah
that that does this stress increases
cortisol
yes it's it's part of it and even you
know uh they already showed that uh
you know a who sleep together where
there's
uh one partner snoring they showed that
for each
snore you know the court has sold spikes
in the partner that doesn't say
that's so interesting you know
studies like this have already been done
and they're fun right but the
the thing is they do have an impact on
your health absolutely
uh um the other thing or on the on the
rupert
on the rupert sheldrake level we could
talk about it as like a morphic field
in a sense um and we're right there next
to each other creating these exposomic
uh uh uh interplays uh between
one another and there's there's no
getting out of it yeah
yeah i had a pleasure of actually
meeting and uh speaking with
uh rupert sheldrake in vancouver uh off
the coast of vancouver at cortes island
uh he was a guest of one of my friends
and i was in fact my best friend in dc
and uh we talked about his morphic field
theory and all that stuff
um but for me it's like uh you know
how do you make it easy for people to
remember right
they know the genes and there's a genome
right
and so essentially your ex posom
right is is that unit that refers to
your environment your total exposure to
the environment
yeah so the genome is to your genes and
your exosome is to your environment may
i think easy
yes and i can give also a very um
brief genomics is what might happen
transcriptomics is what appears to be
happening
proteomics is what makes it happen and
metabolomics is what
is happening now or has happened
like that i like that's what's useful
right i'm treating someone now
so yeah i need what's happening now
right
and uh it's very much influenced by um
you know
i use metabolomics as a as a way to
prove
it right now it's at the level of
metabolism because it's what we can
prove right it's what you can show
objectively
that here here is what's improving right
uh it's like i don't rely on anything
subjective but
usually and uh the case is like i'm
feeling better
right i i i'm i'm uh
i'm feeling better or i feel so much
better or some
some um husbands uh would go i'm only
here because my wife that told me so
then they would come six months later
and they go dr ted you know
i thought i was already feeling better
but i didn't know that it was
possible to feel this way so i tell them
my goal
actually in getting you here is to get
you addicted to the feeling of wellness
so you know that when you get off
balance you know what it is that
uh um that you're off balance right
and you you emphasize now like uh
you know uh like uh simple lifestyle
changes
right uh example you begin to explain
the
mitochondria that they're they're
bacteria inside your cell
you know we call them organelles where
they actually have bacterial origin
right
they have their own dna uh you know um
they're we have
an average about 100 quadrillion of them
in our bodies
you know um our red blood cells used to
have them
but um the mitochondria sacrifice
themselves in order for you to have
hemoglobin
right so um um so and they power you up
right uh they power you up so you you
know that um you know
way before this intermittent fasting
blah blah blah blah 11 years ago
i was already telling my clients that
you know 12 hours of not eating anything
will allow your mitochondria to divide
and regenerate right
it's just like it's just like having a
kitchen that you give a break
right you're cooking non-stop you know
and
if you keep on eating and eating you
know we're a shameful species we have
we have a permission to eat you know 24
hours a day yeah
yeah so um so if you just give it a rest
of 12 hours it will start
regenerating the amount of people that
have successfully shed
50 pounds or more off of their body by
just
fasting and burning fat or extended time
and it's actually really beautiful to
train yourself at young ages
to go on a day fast two-day fast etc
and feel what it's like to burn fat
rather than glucose
right they see for me it's like uh
now you're giving them a scientific
basis for doing
you know uh yes uh and besides
you know alan it's easier for me for
example oh i'm going to change how i eat
no no you can't
what can you promise me that you can do
they can promise me a commitment to the
time that they eat
so i said well you know first try
a feeding window of you know 14 hours
and then uh the next week reduce it to
12 hours
and then 10 hours you know and then um
yeah yeah
exactly and then have a minimum of like
of like um
you know at uh eight hours you know
that's that's your feeding window i
don't like to use
fasting because fasting sounds
deprivatory
so yeah yeah yeah so you hear a feeding
window
and i usually tell them they can eat
whatever they want but then pretty soon
they feel a lot better
when they say how else can i improve my
nutrition and then you introduce the
concept of your microbiota
you know your your gut microbiota they
weigh about
you know uh two kilos uh in there yeah
uh
so there's a thousand yeah
that have two million uh genes
uh 2 000 genes each 2 million genes
which is 100 times more than we have
uh human-wise so that's that's pretty
impressive
yeah the more important fact is that
we now know that the gut the gut is
actually
uh the largest uh immune system of the
body right when i was in
school it was the bone marrow wow you
know it's a gut because because it is
the
gut bacteria that's actually teaching
what's foreign and not foreign
right um wow so so uh you see
this uh these uh reports right the
case reports where um or or analysis
where
uh children born by cesarean section
have a lot more
allergies and immune problems because
there's improper
activation of their immune system
so i have some uh ob gyn enterprising
obj where ants who
know about this so they put a gauze on
on the mother's vagina and they do
the they do the uh cesarean section and
they put a gauze over the face just so
that there would be an inoculation
of the uh bacteria that was supposed to
be there
because what do we find right um and
what do they find in analyzing these
children's bacteria
they find the skin uh bacteria
of the people who handle them first yeah
how messed up is it yeah you know it's
supposed to be there
right uh yeah so okay
yeah so 500 in mitochondria
you know and then you could teach them
about eating which is microbiota and
they got immune system
yes and then we've spoken about
exposomics their lifestyle
and then you you tell them about their
uh sleeping habits right
uh yes yes yes sleep hygiene because
lack of sleep will actually cause memory
problems
huge pathology the main thing that
because evolution
has learned this is that the first thing
that it does for any insult in the body
is to
get inflamed whatever it is yeah it will
activate your and
your nf kappa b right that's the that's
the pathway that will
that's a simple pathway that it will
that it will uh do because
you know it has it has the um
uh the counter pathway to that to quell
it as well
right so um and we know that's the first
thing that it does
right so any any insult you see your
your inflammatory cytokines are
coming up these are molecules you know
uh that that signifi
that signify that your body is getting
inflamed even a simple high sensitivity
serious protein test which
will show you that right but your body's
inflamed even if you're feeling good etc
etc
you see your hsarp is rising you know
that there's stress there's somewhere
and then
you look back and say oh my god you know
i haven't been sleeping uh really
i've been traveling for the past three
days i've been in different time zones
and you see your hscrp shoot up right so
these are the and you can teach them
proper sleep hygiene
and and so on and you know for um
you know that you actually eat uh 200
calories more the next day
when you lack sleep right because the
body feels that it's under
assault it means more energy and
evolutionarily
if the body says you need more energy so
you eat more
right it's it's not it's not like having
the munchies but it's
you actually tend to to eat more right
and then
um and then of course this is this
networks idea that you're talking it's
so deeply networked like that yeah yeah
yeah
and and it's at the cellular level right
and the cells are talking to each other
is why
i say we're looking at the body as an
ecosystem of cells
it's the hollow beyond perspective right
it's a hollow beyond uh perspective
where uh whereas
in illness medicine we look as
individuals as part of a population
right because your your surgical
technique has to work on the population
or your antibiotic has to work on a
population no
we consider you as the population
of organisms yeah yeah so your your your
cells are bacterially derived
yes yes your and your somatic cell is a
result of an
anaerobic bacterium and your
mitochondria which is an aerobic
bacterium
that has a symbiotic relationship in the
past right so
so that's the um uh that's the idea here
it's hellonically layered the human and
then inside of us
is all the complex but then also outside
of us is the civilizational influence
and and that's why when you're looking
at health it's impossible to look at
you as a person you have to look
at you as a whole of bayonne you have to
look
at the the human and all everything
inside and everything in the
civilization outside
all harmoniously affecting the organism
yeah yeah yeah exactly in part in in
fact part of your x person
is the legit um uh the immediate uh
absolutely bacteria viruses etc around
here
absolutely so right now you know um
coronavirus is part of our extra sound
yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so normally uh your own house
will have its own specific you know um
environmental bacteria right that's very
interesting
you mentioned earlier something uh
interesting which is aubrey the grace
model and i i really love the guy
uh and the way he thinks right as a
biogerontologist but
the model that he has actually lends
itself really well to
epigenetics which is the last pillar you
know we have seven pillars right of
health optimization medicine and last
pillar is genetics it lends itself
really well
because um he says like here you are at
the younger period right say you're
21 to 30 your optimal range right and
then at 30
your testosterone begins to decline
that's why i chose 30
right because that's when the
testosterone because you begin to
to uh have to fall apart right and um
what what happens then is that you
the chronic diseases begin to appear
right uh
diabetes you know metabolic diseases uh
cognitive decline
you know uh neurodegenerative diseases
they all begin happening
right and then afterwards it's a period
of disease and then death
right and he says what if we could move
the cells back to before the time
that the chronic diseases appear that
means that the cells would be at a
younger age
right yep yeah and of course you know
uh you already know about the yamanaka
factors right
the nobel laureate uh professor in
monaco japan identified four factors
that can actually
make cells younger and the most recent
um the the most recent uh uh
finding is that they can now actually
make cells younger
without erasing their identity meaning
they don't forget that their muscle
cells or they don't forget
their cells and that's just uh you know
a recent advance but
now we're taking a look at can we it's
like uh the
the best uh metaphor that i use is
actually quite
ugly it's like accumulating plaque on
the teeth right
it's your epigenome and and then so
your gene genetic expression gets
affected like for example if you smoke
and
you you have all this other bad habit
bad habits your
your your um you know uh poorly
methylated or
whatever it is uh toxic lifestyle they
have you know
and and um you um
so when you remove that plaque right
then you could move the cells back to
the younger age
now can we do that the big challenge is
that can we do that now for the entire
body
right and uh so you know david sinclair
you know is uh
do it now doing that for the eye you
know uh can we reverse
the retinal uh the macular degeneration
that occurs
right so uh and uh they
they found out that in in their
laboratory animals they can do so
right in in a close environment so it's
no longer
it it's not no longer appeared for us
this is no longer an anti-aging period
this is now a period of
age reversal yeah right yeah
rejuvenation
through youthful homeostatic capacity
yes
yes but you know it takes many years
of you know it look clinical of course
it didn't catch
didn't catch up with uh medicine
until now until you know i i i'm one of
the people who's pushing hey these tests
are now available yeah yeah yeah
we now can have a a better dashboard
by which to maintain health right yeah i
love the dashboard
so yeah that's why i never use the term
disease prevention
that's also illness medicine crap right
they look at populations
you know that's why vaccines are within
their purview oh interesting so so
basically the the dashboard maybe in the
last
like 100 years has been slowly getting
more and more variables popping up on it
and and now the idea is that there's
there's like sometimes like clinical
metabolomics can maybe
put up um a significant amount of
variables that are really crystal clear
and crisp
and the thing is is that um your role
and a lot of the time people's roles are
to just
grab people and say hello you can add 20
more variables to your dashboard now
please go do that for all of your
clients as soon as possible stop waiting
and my next kind of question around
around this
is that um would it be fair to say that
then um given a synthesis of what you're
talking about with clinical metabolomics
and what aubry de grey
and all these other um of all these
um rejuvenating to homeostatic youthful
homeostatic capacity
would it be fair to say that um our
synthesis of all of you guys in like the
2020s and beyond
is basically going to be something like
a
an an an artificial general intelligence
that has
the entire medical corpus and all of the
um the the the ref or the the reference
pop pop the reference population corpus
um and that then takes in
through sensors that are on my toilet
and everywhere else that are going to be
taking a live stream
of all of those biometrics as my
individual
and then cross-referencing them with the
reference population
and then sending me um interventions
to continue having rej that youthful
homeostatic capacity
that's um that's a utopian future right
but uh you must remember alan that the
reference range will be
also dependent on your race and your
geography yes
uh for example we just did a show on
population genetics when we were in
china and um
hufang zhang was having that exact same
um issue with
how there was only the european data set
yeah yes and that's a problem also with
interpreting the
genetics the genes right now right
because
their references are either chinese or
european
or uh uh or north american right so
so each country um will need to develop
its own reference ranges
that's so interesting wow yes
every country because every country
wow every country that's so interesting
and even
separate even tribes in those countries
look
they eat if you take a look you know
what makes a culture well we were just
talking about the philippines you were
saying there are 76
dialects right yes yeah so then that
means there's all of these different
cult subcultures in the yeah yeah
and the the cuisine is regional right
yeah
it's original there's a region that uses
a lot of
coconut milk there is a region you know
um that uses lots of just totally spicy
stuff
yes you know so so um even in those you
could see
already very very that's why in and this
is what i say
when you're dealing with health
optimization it has to be individualized
we can only do case reports for you what
is being demanded of us is
case work across populations say dude
we don't work with populations we work
with the population of
of uh organisms that is you you are the
ecosystem that we work with
and therefore what is good for
you is not necessarily what's good for
the next person
right we just have a fair idea of what
the body does and what the body needs
because
it's more or less universal that you
know you cannot synthesize vitamins
and that's why they call vitamins
because you take them in right
there are certain essential there's
a certain essential uh minerals that
have to be
uh taken in right um and so on and
and we know that we know that about
our make and model as a human body right
and
one of the biggest problems that we have
is that the megan model of the human
body
is intended for the paleolithic period
right it's not intended for now
we have created a world that is
uh that where our bodies are actually
unsuited for right artificial lights
you know um and uh you know uh polluted
air
and uh you know not exercising you know
you used to to to uh to walk work in the
fields and
and so on and even before agriculture we
walked a lot because we were nomadic
right
so would it be fair to say something
along the lines of
to continue our analogy that's i think
really flourishing flowering right now
would it would it be like that the
vehicle
itself is us in that sense and there's a
make
there's a model there's a yes there's a
year too you said that it was very
important
and then that the older vehicles were
had
that you know the dashboards only had a
couple variables on the i uh
now they're having hundreds and we want
to get that constant measurement
and in that id in that analogy it would
be like you know if you
if your vehicle is manufactured in
the united states or in china or in
south africa or germany or kenya
wherever
it ends up being a
a unique to that specific
make um for your vehicle and you're
going to eat those specific things be
exposed to those certain cultural things
even your language and
and all this type yeah yeah but from an
evolutionary point of view
now we will shift from what you just
said from an evolutionary point of view
right we are actually with the
the world that we have created is the
world for
teslas right gullwing if
you prefer those um but our bodies are
made and model
us human beings is a ford model t ah
this is perfect that's our body is a
ford
ford model t right right yeah and and
the
the world that we have created is
actually suited for a tesla
yeah and and so
we're brilliant species right we can
of course we do we have no so we have no
our model t's have no seat belts and
we're
we're we're in the insane realm of the
internet uh
with all of the yeah and then you know
um
you know uh our bodies are not intended
to eat soylent
for example uh yeah or all the high
fructose corn syrups and
um yes yes yeah so we we are intended
for that period
so what do we do so so for me it's it's
really simple right
now we have some technology so
for example for your artificial light
control your lighting system there are
lighting systems out there now
that can simulate you know a 12 hour you
know or sunrise and sunset and so on and
so forth right if you're staying indoors
um the software is on the computer like
flux and stuff like that are very good
yeah yeah and and then you could uh
you know there's a reason why you use
supplements is because you know that you
are not going to be eating foods rich
and this and that so
you know what when your tests show that
you need them you take them
right because you're getting
deficiencies in them because your body
is used to take
taking them in food otherwise you know
in in in in the olden times in the
paleolithic times
right so a lot of our make and model
is made for that time but we have
created a world
that is not suited for amica model
anymore so what do we do
you know we respond by you know
having air air filters and our cleaners
at our house
right making sure that our our home air
exchanges are adequate
yeah right making sure that our we still
have the same basic needs like
we need to go out to sunlight if you
cannot go to sunlight you know like me i
suffer from seasonal affective disorder
because i'm a tropical boy i need really
more sunlight they have darker
skin right yeah you need you need more
um higher levels of vitamin d so what i
do
i have a vitamin d lamp that has uvb and
i exposed myself so you you
you essentially uh uh compensate
by using technologies that are available
to you
or um um things that we have invented
right in order to compensate for it
because there's no going back
right i cannot bring you to a time when
there was no electric bulb
or no radio or no electricity
you know that's not possible anymore so
why not make your
you know retrofit your your home to be
emf shielded
right um interesting
so and that's the reason why
you know people say they they're
biohacking all sorts of things right
this is a framework by which you can
make
you can hang all of your hacks you could
look at
epigenetics you know uh bioenergetics
uh microbiota uh got microbiota
mitochondria
exposomics chronobiology evolutionary
medicine
and you could hang all of your hacks in
there in a logical way
right there's a logic now you're not
just saying
oh it's because they're saying it's good
for me or if you want to help someone as
a practitioner
say right um because i know that there
would be less doctors interested in this
and there would be more practitioners
who actually would be interested in
doing this is now there's a logical way
where you could hang all of your hacks
oh that belongs here or that belongs
here yes yes you're not
you're not haphazard anymore with the
way you do things with the way you help
your clients
right so i'm doing this because x yeah
yeah this is this is super interesting
on an
on an economic perspective because we've
been we've been rolling i want to i want
to hit
still some um really interesting points
that was our
that was kind of our most heavy section
um
which is the thesis of of an ethos of
what um you care about and what
all these great leaders in the fields of
biotechnology especially care about
now are you sure i care about that
[Laughter]
i want to know this uh we we can end on
this um
perspective on that we can end that
section on this specific perspective
around that
which is it's very interesting
how the amount of money
that is sort of spent on this what like
what like people like jessica zitter and
other people have called like this
end-of-life conveyor belt and palliative
care
um and like people just having you know
dying preferences
and being able to like spiritually
connect on the way out or all this type
of different type stuff
but also what all the problems that we
have with
um heart disease and alzheimer's and all
these other
ins cancers and all these other problems
that we have um
that there's so much money that we can
quantify that is spent on
the disease of biomarkers versus when we
spend them on these um medical
biomarkers health biomarkers multi-omics
these health biomarkers
and then so what's interesting is that
so there's both a significant amount of
economic cost that we decrease on that
downstream end
but then we also spend more money on
this upstream end as well so there's
actually
in a sense there's a continuation of
great economic
um flourishing so it's like you would
subscribe in a sense to maybe
a five dollar a month or ten or twenty
dollar a month or whatever it is
um plan where your constant stream of
biometrics is being fed up into that
agi corpus um that is then
taking your individual and
cross-referencing that with the
publishing then providing you with
with intervention and but ultimately
ultimately
what um you said in one of your graphics
which i really liked a lot
which was that um it's so simple in
terms of
these you know if you do think about it
like you're continuing the analogy
like you said the model t itself that is
now in the tesla world
um like we are that you can do basic
things to very quickly
ramp up your model t to be closer to a
tesla
which are basically the most ancient
wisdoms
are you've said um sleep well eat well
hydrate well breathe well move
well sun well ground well relate well
love well and if you do those things you
can very
easily work your way into a healthier
and this is the connection that i think
we can talk about now
it's basically the connection between
enlightenment
and health or awakening and health so
the more
in a sense that you recognize the
the unity of all being the unity of all
existence
that deep interconnectedness of all and
also
that source that you come from that you
are
that we are that and that the more that
you really
embody that that um the impenetrable
peace and the causeless joy and you
basically stay in that state
and you make art from that state the
healthier you
are on all your health biomarkers
yes um uh you you touch on something
that's uh
you know what's uh interesting is that
illness medicine always demands
proof right uh and that's because
they're
based on population based thinking right
so
when you're and they're you're talking
about quantity the quantity of people
that have survived because see they're
after
survival rates right there that's that's
their measure
that the measure of the success of any
intervention that they
do is after survival rate so they're
after
quantity and for me i'm after quality
right
what's the quality uh uh one of the
things that i learned early on
um in medical informatics when
i was
doing you know uh research on on how
much is
the value of life and uh you know in in
dollars you know how much is one life
worth and all that yeah
we we do those kinds of research those
are done right
um you you don't know that the actual
reason
of the people that provide you with life
insurance those are all computed
and those are all known right but um
when you
when you look at all of the stuff it's
like
what is the quality of your life now and
the thing that i i learned there is that
there are outcomes that are worse than
death
right and we don't like to admit that
that there are outcomes
worse than death but that is already the
finding of studies
what in the 1990s right uh
we know that and and uh you know only
the most ignorant of us
would of doctors would say well i have i
have the
uh i took an oath well you know that's
that's just for hollywood
right um so we
we already have established a kind of
thing so
we now have to turn our focus on what's
the quality of life that we're living
and the quality of life that you live is
actually inside you
right yeah yeah
wrote a famous book right wherever you
go there you are
so um so what's what's the status of the
default mode network inside your brain
are you know are you too
self-referential all the time
but for me it's like uh what is uh you
know how do you live life with a sense
of equanimity
and um i was asked this question one
time
uh is uh uh by a psychiatrist and said
dr ted you know your health optimization
medicine model which
seven pillars is just brilliant but how
do you
include spirituality right in
health optimization and i said oh you
know it's really very simple
right um uh you know that the
dmt is called the spirit molecule
so just give the person dmt and
you solve the spiritual imbalance
it's the fastest way to just
obliterate the ego obliterate the ego
and and just melt melt right into the
infinite consciousness
just melt right into it and then
hopefully you can re-baseline
the big thing is to re-baseline after
anthogenic experiences unleashing the
divine within
but then can you re-baseline to that
level well re re-baselining is actually
done through practice like
exactly exactly or um or other practices
that actually um point out to you the
illusoriness of the self
right i you know ego is a very
heavily laden term you know that's
freudian it's your sense of self
importance
but so i i tend to use this
self-referential system
more than i use the ego but people
understand the ego because
it's everything from which everything is
centered right
but that center is an illusion right
it's it's uh
it's just created by the brain it's uh
it's part of
what evolved to give us a sense of
continuity
but it's also the source of our
suffering and if you take a look at our
website uh for you know transcriptions
is a brand of my company called smarter
not harder
right and uh if you take a look at our
mission there is to decrease suffering
in ourselves and to decrease suffering
in others knowing that there is no other
exactly beautiful so so
so we come to a definition of what's
suffering you know
uh for me suffering is really very
simple um
you know in in in common parlance for me
suffering is
identifying with the self or you know
getting lost with your thought
you know you think the thought is you
right like uh
so there is someone that's owning the
experience
obsessed it's about someone that the
layers of identity that we
that we've put on as onion layers
yeah and that we haven't ever peeled off
we gotta
to feel the source to feel it and live
from that source yeah and and for me
you know i'm and i have less grandiose
plans
uh you know uh i have a simple
definition of enlightenment which is
you know the cessation of suffering and
which is suffering
the source of suffering is the ego which
is an illusion anyway
that is that clings to or is averse to
certain things so it wants this doesn't
want that once this is one that
and soon all of those wants once once
accumulate right you want more profits
you want more
therefore you're going to pollute the
oceans more and therefore you're going
to use
um child labor more therefore you're
going to
to a traffic human once more you know
all in the name of one one
one right so and therefore for me that
is suffering
you know uh if you the clinging and
aversion of the ego
is the root of suffering
yes yes there's a there's a balance
here and i'm curious how you align with
this idea
it's called like the dreamed symphony in
the sense that
the infinite consciousness creates the
dreamed
reality that is that is this and then
there's the
multiverse which is all of the dreamed
realities this is just one
observers and there's many other
observers
happening an an infinite amount
of illusory finity in a sense
that is happening and so here you here
here we have this this um dimensionless
singularity that is uh indivisible
and it's indescribable the the
the dow that can be named is not the
eternal dao okay so we have that and
then now we
are the um this the dream symphony and
so here's the symphony that's happening
now in the symphony i'm playing the
violin
but you're playing the trombone and then
someone else is playing the clarinet and
someone else is playing the cello
and we're all playing different melodies
and different harmonies
and people that are playing out of tune
are people like you described that are
suffering they're still suffering
they're still
in the service to self mentality and
people that are playing
in tune are playing in the service to
other
mentality everything's in service
they're they've they've a clear
gnosis of the divine
that they are and what and what's going
on they're very
clear um seer of truth consciousness
how do you resonate with that dreamed
symphony analogy
man that's [ __ ] heavy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but i i mean
the one thing that i i you know i i
you know i i i told you just with with
friends here
and one thing that i usually totally
inject into all of these things is
levity
you can never be too [ __ ] serious
about
anything right yes and you know i
i you know my pedigree is in
neuroscience and i'm still a
neuroscientist and even i'm a physician
you know
even in in as a physician i still deal
with the brain
so let's bring down
uh so for me right
right now we're trying to there's a 20
million
uh dollar prize now the templeton to to
uh
to uh uh elicit the the
mechanism of consciousness right and one
is
the causal um
model which is the integrated
information theory right and one is the
causal model or the non-causal model
which is the global
workspace theory among others right
you know because my interest uh in this
is still in in consciousness
and then there's of course you know um
philosophers
you know that you know they say well
maybe it's a pansei kissim
whether or not it's inherent or emerging
fansite is something or you don't know
who wins right but you know
my thing is this is fun and this is yeah
answer to your question yes my answering
question
ever since i was a kid all the way to
now or so
my first experience with ayahuasca for
example
it's as if a rug was pulled from under
me as a strict
scientist you know just looking at the
world with this
you know and then you is if a rug is
pulled out
under you and suddenly that there are
dimensions out there
that were unavailable for you before
right yeah so so uh and then it's easier
for you to
actually um realize
that the self is an illusion you know
and then now
physics is saying that space time we're
losing space time to be
it's an illusion right and
we we now have uh i have people saying
that
all we're doing in this world is like we
are just a user interface with
fitness functions that's donald huffman
right
uh we evolved we see an apple we see
this only because
that's you know that's our user
interface in order to
to to execute our programs or survival
and reproduction
right and uh so uh
but but for me the side guys the spirit
of everything else is a [ __ ] game
yeah you know you when you you best
enjoy the game you know when when you um
an
mmorpg massive multiplayer online
role-playing game
yeah this is what i this is what i say
you know
um it's very difficult to convince
people unless they have done programming
that what you believe in
is not necessarily true right right
so but the the biggest punch that i give
them is that when you were a kid you
believed
you believed in santa claus right and
then you were able to shed that belief
that's right other beliefs are harder to
shed
yeah right and when you're programming
for example if you set a global variable
if you said that god is true then
do the following if jesus christ is true
then do the following if
if you know gautama buddha is true then
do the following
so you could see that you know whatever
it is that's
said in there that's right it's yeah
it's it's it's programmatic
right it's super programmatic but but
that
but that's hard for us to accept right
because
it's easier if you take an integral view
so when when you when you embrace all
that is and especially all eight billion
of these
individual players and what they see as
true as their scripts
if you have any that's important as
their script scripts
yeah but the thing is they cannot see
beyond the script if
we can augment their awareness beyond
the script
to the integral embrace of this
beautiful mystery
and expressing unique gifts then we are
into that more harmonious world our
hearts know is possible
yeah that's why can i combine some
molecules
that can balance the default mode
network in the past past not past
positive network
in such a way right that it is evident
to you that there needs to be no owner
of the experience
right that there um that it is there
only so that it provides
its continuity for you to have a story
every day because that's what allowed
you to survive in evolution
right so it's embracing
that but going beyond that
right and when we notice that
i i i tell people this that's why i i
tell people
you know all of us should be educated
after evolutionary biology evolution
psychology we should be educated in
evolutionary game theory
we don't realize that much of our
behavior is dictated by that
you know by zero some dynamics
yeah yeah why is it why is the tit for
that game why is it successful all the
time
you know and so on like but people will
go wow those are very difficult
concepts right we need to tell better
stories
which links us to the very beginning
when we tell better stories
hard it's hard to tell it's hard to tell
engaging stories in science right unless
you engage
them and when when well well we have to
tell the story the big metaphysical
story
that is like in a sense like the harry
potter of
of you know like that like when we can
do that
then we can really inspire that
awakening for example you know um
right now you know we don't distinguish
when we're teaching
kids we don't distinguish between you
know teaching them religion versus
teaching them spirituality which are two
different things
yeah right yeah we just shove in them
and
the same in these types of of religious
neurosis
and they end up having the same
religious neurosis as
well there's a very clear baby in the
bath water that we can
lift up and yeah and bring up the spirit
and
that requires and and uh you know
it requires a lot of good stories told
like a lot of education
yeah it requires a lot or what we can do
is we can say okay how can we take that
what looks like a lot of education
how can we compress that down pareto
efficient
into a couple of you know stories that
can really awaken people i think we can
do that and that's pretty much what
not only this project um is that we'll
be oh
i i don't know i'm kidding yeah
yeah yeah yeah but but no but this is
why
we are so passionate also about the
space of
um you know what like los angeles is
doing with able to um put together like
the best
animated content as well like why is you
know pixar's like inside out so popular
or why is um like rick and morty so
popular in that sense can we make it
into
you know or like spongebob squarepants
for like the the kids
like how can we tell a story that so
deeply or like game of thrones and harry
potter
that's so deeply interwoven with
metaphysics though
um and that animation and storytelling
that's what we're passionate about in
2021
yeah you you can also do the flip side
right yes tell what is that what is my
my my my friends know that i have an
allergy to stories because
they have always [ __ ] us up you know
if they're just
we are predisposed to stories that's why
we have all of these conspiracy theories
we were born to gossip and and so on
um you can also do the flip side
uh like we can teach
uh children to meditate earlier
you have a practice earlier in a
neuroscientific way
right here is how you observe the
contents of your consciousness
right that's part of what i'm describing
in terms of metaphysical stories
yeah yeah observing the contents of your
consciousness
right early right yes realizing that the
sound right
is just another content of consciousness
attention itself
is another arising in consciousness so
you
see all of these arising consciousness
and
especially when you teach them to kids
before they develop
that that uh hardened sense of ego
ego i want this i don't want that i want
is they have this skill to take a look
at their desires and aversions and say
okay
should will i follow this desire or will
i follow will will i
get rid of this because i'm averse to it
a
yeah there is a pause that happens
right before they actually act
there's that and in that pause the
entire destiny of
your life outcome in the world it
happens
yeah yes because uh maybe
it's you're gonna scream and yell at
someone
who is going to be you know the most
influential figure in your life and you
lose it
right so so it gives you that uh
you know it gives it stops you from
being reactive
into being responsive yeah and all it
takes
is being able to examine for me it's
just a simple skill it's
it's difficult it's a difficult skill
that's why you can turn it into a mental
game
right uh of of uh being able to identify
your thoughts
investigation into the nature of your
being and
rupert spyra uses a very good modern day
analogy which
is the simple screen because if you
think about that
infinite consciousness as your being as
that screen
and then having all of the different
cravings and aversions and scenes that
come up of the
illusory multidisciplinary multiplicity
and diversity of objects and people
as as the as the scenes in the screen in
the movie
that you realize that you are that
blissful eternal
infinite screen that's always having
these different
um slices of the movie so i
yeah you're right though that that first
principle at the young age you know
there's so many indigenous cultures
around the world
like the baby in their bathwater is the
fact that
they have what you described which is
that depth
of of truth that depth of
interconnection that depth of unity
that depth of understanding the nature
of their own
mind and you know buddha was one of the
best
uh indicators and adi shankara was
another
massive one ramana maharshi these they
were excellent adam at that
investigation so and and
i mean infants are are fantastic they're
great until we [ __ ] them up
right because they are
you know evolutionarily and uh and uh
biologically programmed right and then
we begin the sociocultural programming
with education
you know uh with um education with
what the pair how the parents raise them
with uh uh
you know the the environment that
they're in so they're continuously
getting programmed and yes uh in fact
one of the things that i
um uh interesting the script being the
most
open and integral and understanding the
nature of mind and reality at the
youngest age
that's great yeah and and and uh also
you know aside from from i said going
going the opposite
uh it's teaching kids you know how to
examine the contents of your
consciousness
and why they need to do so it's an
essential skill
that will not make them suffer in the
future exactly right because they know
that they're just arisings in
consciousness right and the other thing
is
when it's too late for you what i say is
that
um you know when you're 21 22 years old
or whatever
just go out and
and try to examine all of the beliefs
that were placed in there
by your parents by your siblings by your
teachers
and everything and see if they're still
working for you
you know uh all the lines of code
yeah yeah those those those those may
not be yours
right yeah as i say you know you can set
something to false
you can or my favorite is if you don't
need the variable anymore you put a
semicolon
to it yeah archive archive some code and
update that with some new lines that are
more integral
yeah yes and then bearing
that if you're still all older it's like
what kind of
molecules can we use in order to break
through that right so
you have you have a psilocybin
you have mdma you know you have all of
this things
that can break through and which is you
know uh they're used therapeutically
but they're also consciousness racing
molecules you know they
are non-addicting consciousness-raising
molecules they're not addicting because
they don't raise their
dopamine at all right yeah we know the
mechanism
we we know the mechanism for addiction
right so so there's no more reason why
they say oh these are
because they cause addiction they won't
yeah
hacking your script i i i don't know of
anyone who
would like to take uh ayahuasca for fun
right yeah we do it we do it to hack
our script that's why we do it yeah
although you know i hacked ayahuasca to
my version of it called pharmaca because
i didn't want to vomit
right yeah yeah yeah yeah which is the
future
yeah it's the no vomit ayahuasca because
i yeah yeah i couldn't for the life of
me just
you know yeah continue vomiting but
these are the
you know these are the kinds of of
things that are available
you know um on the flip side of telling
stories it's
you know educating children that
teaching them
how to to meditate and uh you know and
making it a practice
and making it a habit for younger people
to examine the contents of their
consciousness right
for us it's difficult but if you start
them young it's easy for them
because it's like seeing your optic
blind spot
as sam harris likes to say you know once
it's pointed out to you
you cannot you know not remember seeing
it
right and then uh there's this period
where there's a time we should examine
what beliefs are in there
and you know and then we have now this
uh
um uh psychedelics that allow us to
investigate our mind and
uh allow us to change uh our scripts and
so on
and for me it's as i like to say those
are like
bodybuilding steroids now you use them
only for a while and then after that you
will have to do the exercises yourself
off cycle yes exactly
and and that's how you know for for me
like yes we're advancing in the world
and and so on but
are we alleviating the suffering of
people
so yes we have all of this high-tech
stuff and we have all of this biometrics
and so on and so forth
but fundamentally you know uh i'm not
even saying
uh anything about happiness you know
we're not wired for happiness
world for survival and reproduction
happiness is an inside job
but for me happiness is not suffering so
so if we can teach it's a it's a skill
that can be learned right um observing
the contents and
not being identified as you said not
identifying
with the ego or not identifying with the
self-referential system
and knowing that things just arise you
know these are just
neural networks that fire you know as i
like to say
as a neural network guy you know when
you see something
your uh visual neural network fires when
you hear something
your auditory neural network fires you
know and
it is in the same space where your
thoughts arise they're also just neural
networks firing where your emotions
arise your limbic system
uh neural networks are firing they're
all just neural networks
firing and if you could see that that
when when they fire in such a way that
there's
it seems that there is someone
orchestrating them
that's where we actually get [ __ ] up
right when they when we when we when we
uh
when we um begin to own that we can
control these things that's why
the most difficult thing in meditation
right is like i want to control my
thoughts no you can't you have allowed
them
to go right and see that they disappear
they appear in the same space of
consciousness as everything else
that's what you see what you hear you
know what you feel
you know the pressure in your body the
concept of you
having a face and so on they're all
appearing
in the same consciousness space as where
thought arises where emotion arises
and it's a skill you know that can be
taught
to be able to see the arisings of those
and you could see suffering decrease
and when suffering decreases then you
could see
creativity arises right
because you're not craving for something
anymore
right you are you are in equanimity
as i tell people i don't like
extreme happiness and deep whirlpools of
sadness
i just like you know gentle waves of
things
so so when you learn when you learn that
then you you know you can gamify it
if you want right we have friends that
are doing that yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and uh and so you begin
you begin not to take yourself
seriously exactly that's the levity
piece yeah i agree
i agree begin not to take yourself
seriously um
you begin to see well you know what
purpose you know
it's like you said whatever purpose you
like you know uh
and so it's like you know we we grow up
thinking that you know there is purpose
and meaning and so on and so forth and
you realize
like no you're the one setting all of
that so
you set your script properly you set
your script
amen you set your script
one more time you you
set your script script however
you should be aware from where the
script
is is coming from you are talking about
the source
exactly where does from where does the
script arrive beautiful
beautiful from words yeah
yeah and and when there's [ __ ] up
scripts in there
man because it's [ __ ] up it's 100
your ability 100 you can
like you said contemplate what is
written in there and
um go through the experiential practices
there's all these modalities
for for that that exists now
yes okay that last last thing yeah
good don't believe in what you think
right i have this thing i always say
um and this would be a good end to your
our podcasts here yes yes don't think
feel yeah don't feel
so don't think that you are love don't
feel that you're in love be loved be it
and then we just butterfly effect that
out
all over i love that i love it
that's the logo of home boat by the way
yes it is
yeah i know i know that's everybody
you have to check out the links in the
bio
um thank you very much for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you all thank you
thank you ted thank you so much for
coming on the show and joining us this
has been
so enlightening across so many different
aspects i've loved it i've loved it um
and you could guys you can find so many
of the things that ted has been talking
about in those links in the bio below
i highly recommend going to homehope.org
and watching his fundamentals video it
breaks down
a lot of the wisdom that he's been
communicating in a very strong
educational way
it's super awesome check that out also
biobalanceinstitute.com
introscriptions.com check all of that
out all those links
and also um continue supporting
the artists entrepreneurs the scientists
the spiritual leaders in your
communities and around the world that
you believe in you can support ted you
can support us and our show
our links are in the bio below as well
and
go and build the future manifest your
dreams
and destiny into the world build that
more beautiful world our hearts
know is possible and get at the front
of this massive evolution of
biotechnology
get at the front and share it and get
inspired about that
this is the future be part of the major
pseudopod of the amoeba that brings
the society along with it with enough
momentum
that's right the pacer of the cultural
zeitgeist is
is moving yes yeah much love thank you
for tuning in
and we will see you soon everyone peace
[Music]
you